All right.
Welcome to Digging Deeper
on Wednesday night here at Henderson Hills.
Grateful to have you here,
and we're grateful to get to do this in a free country,
a free, um, location that we've got, the comfort level
that we have here, the great food we have beforehand.
It's, uh, a gift. We don't take that
for granted from the Lord's hand.
And so hopefully you can remember God's goodness in that
as well tonight.
And we look forward to studying a little more deeply what we
touched on briefly on Sunday.
Uh, so thankful for that. Thankful for you being here.
And, uh, so I preface all this with, uh, the reality that,
uh, I got a lot of questions already.
And so we may, may or may not get to open q and a.
We'll see how that goes, uh,
as naturally you can imagine with this one.
Uh, but, uh, if you have something, of course, feel free
to ask.
Uh, Aaron's here, tr is scheduled to be here,
but he's involved in a surgery right now.
Uh, not that he's getting surgery.
He is a surgeon, so he's trying to make it here.
Uh, I'll have Aaron and TR come up, or just Aaron later,
but find us in the lobby afterwards.
Make sure you have those questions. Email us.
We want to talk through this, uh,
but also realize that we won't get everything
answered in a few minutes.
And these are complicated
and, um, debated for
2000 years, really.
And so we're trying to figure this out in a few minutes.
Uh, and, and there's implications, there's questions.
And, and so, again, remember in this series,
we're looking at the big rocks first.
That was what we spent seven weeks on at least
a few of those big rocks.
And then we got to these smaller rocks,
which we talked about that are what churches, in a sense,
quote unquote, divide over things
that we can't worship in the same worship setting together
because of infant baptism versus believers baptism,
for example, or speaking in tongues.
And, and so next Sunday, this coming Sunday,
we're gonna get to the sand.
We're gonna look at ways that we can disagree
and differ on things and still be in the same body,
still be in the same small group even.
But this one, this idea of reform theology
and those kind of things that surround, that, the terms
that all surround, that it, it is kind of, uh,
a small rock in a sense that that's our flavor as a church.
And, and so I wanna make sure that you're clear about that.
We don't wanna hide that.
But at the same time, it's not something that we're trying
to jam down everybody's throat as this system
being the only right system.
It's how we interpret how we come up with, uh,
our theological ideas.
But, but really this is also in the same vein, a kind of a,
a kind of sand issue
where we can differ on the nuances of these things.
And if it talks about a big rock,
then we gotta land together on that.
But if it's an implication or if it's understanding
and how to interpret that,
then maybe there can be some difference.
We'll talk a little bit about that as we go through.
Uh, but I also wanna talk about this just upfront.
This is not new for our church.
This is something that this church has held for, uh, 30
years-ish, somewhere around there.
This is where we've landed as a church.
So we're not just coming up with this
and kind of taking a stance
and saying, Hey, we're now this, this is what we have been.
So this is not new. Just trying to articulate a distinctive,
uh, if you haven't heard that before, that's okay,
because this is not what we're making the flag
of our church wanna make it a, a reality, a skeleton
of course, but also realize that this is,
this is something that's not new.
We're coming up with something different.
This is what we have believed.
It's also what most baptists have believed throughout
history, uh, apart from the last 150 years about where, uh,
there's been some new waves of things coming up.
But most Baptists were reformed in their belief systems.
And so that made kind of jar some of your categories.
But that's, that's the reality
of when you look back at history of, of Baptist life,
it's been mostly this.
Plus, when we talk about these things, we're not promoting
or, or championing a person.
Uh, this is not because John Calvin or Martin Luther
or anyone else said these things.
What we care most is about
what God's word says about these things.
And so whenever you feel like there's a bit of this, uh,
I get kind of pushed back a little bit in my own beliefs,
and you're feeling that a little bit, if it forces you
to go study your Bible, that's a good thing, right?
We want everyone to be able to, to be encouraged
that this is what we need to be doing.
Uh, so when you go, go read and, and go study
and go try to dig out some of the implications
and where you can get to that as well.
So just as all preface material, let, let's keep
that in mind as we go to it.
And as we come to it, let's approach this issue with respect
and love for a believer in Christ, a brother,
a sister in Christ that might differ a little bit on
where they land in these things.
Now, this is not something that we should be, uh, I,
I've alluded to this, others have said it this way.
Cage stage in our belief system where like you're just going
around looking for theological cage matches
for fights all the time.
Like that's not, uh, that's not what this is about.
Shouldn't be what this is about.
So we're just gonna look at the scriptures
and, uh, there's gonna be res as a result
of the study at any study like this,
there's gonna be questions,
there's gonna be mysterious pieces of this.
Some of these questions will be unanswerable
until we get to the other side.
Uh, but the, the scriptures that we're gonna look at and,
and really philosophical arguments
that we look at in these things, both for
and against whatever system that you might ascribe to, uh,
there really is that, which is why it is something we have
to be holding carefully, loosely.
We have to hold it humbly.
But since there are questions, I mentioned this on Sunday,
the way we start matters.
So either way, you start in this idea, this any system,
either way you start, there's gonna be questions in the
middle, there's gonna be questions about implications.
So either way, there's going to be questions.
And so what we've chosen to do is just simply say,
we're gonna start top down.
You could start bottom up, kind of with humans first,
and then figure out implications and questions
and how that works out with God and who he is.
We've chosen to start with God,
and then work down from there
and figure out the questions that will inevitably come.
Yes. But we feel like there's fewer questions that way.
And we feel like the answers that we wouldn't get
are answered by, oh, God is God.
We're just not gonna understand that fully.
So top down theology.
So when we get stuck, there's gonna be times in,
in our study today,
in our study on our own, we're gonna get stuck.
And so I, I was talking to
with our staff yesterday about this,
and Jimmy Quinn, one of
our staff members, been here a long time.
He said this, they had a panel
one time with college students.
They kind of came to this idea
that top down theology kind of idea too.
But, but when we get stuck, what do we come back to?
So think about this, any theology that makes more of God
and less of me is good theology.
So when we get stuck, there's questions we're like, ah,
I don't know how to answer this.
Or maybe there's two options, or four options or 10 options.
Any theology that makes more of God
and less of me is a good theology.
So when we have to default, when we have to kind
of step back and say, oof, I don't know the answer to
that one, the best case, the best way is just to say, okay,
God, I'm trusting you
and this is what I believe happens here, and,
and that makes more of you than less of me.
So that's, if you get stuck, keep coming back to that idea.
Top down. Alright, so I thought it'd be helpful
to talk about why we even needed a
reformation to begin with.
So when we say reformed,
we don't just necessarily mean specifically a
system of belief.
Why did we need a reformation to begin with?
Well, the Protestant Reformation was a widespread
theological revolt in Europe against the abuses
and totalitarian control of the Roman Catholic Church.
So there were reformers, we say Martin Luther, ZW Lee,
Calvin, many others.
They were protesting various unbiblical practices
of the Catholic church.
And what they were promoting was a return to sound doctrine
to the apostolic doctrine, uh,
that they would reference even
Augustine in the four hundreds.
You'd reference even before that as well.
Uh, but that's what they were seeing.
And so we'll talk a little bit
more about what they were seeing.
But the precipitating event
of the Protestant Reformation generally considered
to be Luther protesting the church
by posting 95 theses on the door in Wittenberg,
where he listed out all the things
that he saw that were wrong.
And it put him on the, the hit list, really,
from the church at that point.
But that was October 31st, 1517.
So as a background to that, it's important
to understand why they were so, uh, angry, upset about this,
because the Catholic claim of apostolic succession was part
of the problem where the doctrine says the line
of Roman Catholic popes extends all the way back
to the apostle Peter.
So the current pope they would say is in the apostolic
line from Peter.
And so that makes them, in their minds,
the only true church.
And it gives the pope this preeminence over all churches,
everywhere that he has this line unbroken line.
Even the way he speaks as cathedra is,
is apostolic authority.
And so because of their belief in that,
then Catholics place the teaching of the church
and the tradition teaching
of the church on equal status with scripture.
So it's not scripture by itself as scripture
and tradition scripture and the Pope's
teaching in that sense.
And so that's one of the major differences today, of course.
But it was one of the foundational issues
leading to the reformation.
Now, there was some resistance before Luther,
but they were kind of small, isolated.
It came to a head when Luther posted those
challenge, the authority of the Pope.
And specifically the issue came around the selling
of indulgences where the,
the Roman Catholic Church was selling these indulgences
as a means of releasing people from having to
perform penitence for their sins.
It would also get people out of purgatory faster.
Uh, this is one quote, as soon
as the penny jingles into the money box,
the soul flies out of purgatory.
So they were selling, which Luther's saying,
these church officials are teaching people,
they could literally buy their way into the kingdom
of heaven or buy their way into God's favor or someone else.
And so the, the Pope had deteriorated
into these manmade doctrines,
and so he's like, this is wrong.
This is way off. Well, the Roman Catholic Church
did not heed that call.
They dug in its heels and sought
to silence the reformers, often violently.
And so that's what precipitates begins.
What we know as the Protestant protest,
Protestant reformation at the heart of reformation,
is four basic questions.
How is a person saved? Where does religious authority lie?
What is the church and
what is the essence of Christian living?
So that's kind of the genesis of Luther.
He's thinking through these things and he's talking about
that that's what led them to develop what we now know
as the five solas sola being the Latin word for alone.
And so these are the five essential points of doctrine that,
that separate Protestantism from Roman Catholicism.
So they, uh, they resisted the demands.
The Roman Catholic Church resisted the demands to reform.
Uh, and so they, they began telling these ref,
the reformers, saying, you recant or you're going to die.
They called them anathema, cursed in this,
but they didn't recant burned alive at the stake, many
of them to uphold what they saw
as biblical doctrines about salvation
and about these truths of the church and authority.
And so the first one was Solas scriptura scripture alone,
that the bible's the sole authority, not scripture
and tradition scripture on its own.
Uh, everything else is measured by that.
So we, we have that as number one.
Number two, salvation by grace alone,
God's undeserved favor, not by any work we do,
that God is the sole cause of salvation in grace to us.
God's work by His Holy Spirit raise us from death to life,
then soe, which is salvation by faith alone,
that we're justified by faith in Christ alone,
not by the works of the law.
It's faith that is imputing righteousness to us,
that that's the standard that we meet only by faith.
Number four was in Christ alone.
So is Christus as salvation's found in Christ alone.
No one, nothing else can save.
And the, uh, you're not saved through the church.
You're saved through Christ. You're saved in some ways.
Um, you're on, you're not saved
unless Christ's redemption is declared.
The gospel's not been declared, if that's not part of it.
Uh, and if faith in his resurrection is not solicited.
So it's in Christ alone.
And then for the glory of God alone.
So de Gloria and salvation's of God has been accomplished
by God for his glory alone.
So our lives magnify him in his presence,
under his authority for his glory.
That's the heart of the Protestant Reformation.
Those five truths.
They're at the heart of it, uh, that the,
they're calling the Roman Catholic Church to return
to biblical teaching.
They didn't see it. So they began starting their own.
And that's what you see happen in Protestant churches coming
about as a result.
Okay? So that's the genesis of this.
Now, in talking about this, I've already had the question,
well, what if somebody just wants to study the Bible?
Like don't, don't tell me all of these things about systems
and why do I need all this stuff?
It just seems like it's cluttering things.
Just gimme the Bible. It's all I need. Okay?
It's a great, it's number one in the Solas, right?
And that's okay. The problem is you're gonna come up
with your own system, right?
It's going to come out in some way where you have
to piece together things within the Bible
to understand how they work together.
Now, you don't have to be harsh about it, but,
but the reality is we're going to come up with things
that we have to tie and work together and mesh somehow.
And, and so that's the reality. Yes.
I I we want you to just study the Bible. Absolutely. Great.
The problem is you, you have to figure out
how it works together.
And so that's where we come to these sorts of things.
That's okay, great, let's do it.
But, but let's talk about how to handle it.
I also wanna address this.
I is is this some kind of new revelation?
So there was a heresy back in Jesus' day
and a couple of hundred years after called gnosticism.
And the word agnosis starts
with a gnosis in the Greek means knowledge.
So there was this perspective,
you can read it in the New Testament,
that they're talking about this kind of special revelation
that they're getting special knowledge
that nobody else can have,
and that was trying to elevate themselves above others
in the church, that they got some special revelation from
God, that they, this person over
here, they need to listen to it.
God told me that we shouldn't
eat this or we shouldn't do this.
And so there was this claim for special revelation,
and it was a special knowledge, a secret knowledge
that has been asked about this, where like, okay,
I, I don't, I don't see that, and I, I don't read
and I don't see those words.
I don't see those things in the Bible.
And so did you guys get some kind of special revelation?
And this is a super class of Christian,
if you don't understand this,
you're a lesser believer if you're not getting this all
together, like, is this some kind of n gnosticism?
Is that what we're talking about here?
Well, that can breed arrogance
and it can breed defeatism on the other side who don't
mesh line up fully.
And so I want to be clear that this is not, that
this is simply an effort to read God's word,
understand it, its implications, try
to answer the questions, and that leads to statements, leads
to creeds, it leads to beliefs.
Yeah. But this is not something that you have to get
to some second level of heaven to figure out.
And if you're not there, then you're some lesser Chris.
No, that's not the case. All
of us are still growing in our
ability to understand these things.
We should all walk humbly into these realities
and never feel like we have the whole handle on this
or the corner of the market on this.
So don't think of it as some levels of,
of spirituality based on how much you know
and how well you understand these things.
That's not true at all. We're all in process.
So what then is reformed theology?
Well, as I've already said, broadly speaking, it's
any system of belief
that traces its roots back to the reformation.
So in essence, we're all, if we're not Catholics,
we're all reformed in that sense.
Of course, they, they traced their beliefs back
to scripture, right?
Solas scriptura. So we're not saying that coming
with a new system, they're, they're tracing back
to the apostolic doctrine through people like Augustine
and the INE Creed and other places that tried to articulate
what the apostles were teaching.
It's not new. They're just trying to
rere remind everybody about what we had at
that time 1500 years ago.
This is what we believe, right? As a church, as Christians.
So when we think of though, specifically, of course,
that's generically ref reformation
generally, and more specifically about
what we typically say, capital R reform theology holds
to the authority of scripture, the sovereignty of God,
salvation by grace through Christ,
and the necessity of evangelism.
Again, I'm gonna try to deal with some of the questions
that come up with this, but sometimes
called covenant theology.
It emphasizes the covenant God made with Adam,
and then the covenants you see throughout the Old Testament
all the way until the new covenant, which came
through Jesus Christ.
So it's, it's typically called that.
And there's no dispensations, no distributions.
It's it's covenant throughout
that there's one covenant really, that God has, has strung
through the red, uh, you could call it the scarlet thread,
all the way back from Adam, all the way
through the Old Testament into the new covenant in Jesus.
So walk through those again, authority of scripture
that the Bible is the inspired, authoritative word of God.
It's sufficient in all matters of faith
and practice, uh, the sovereignty of God.
That God has absolute control over all creation,
that he has foreordained, we'll talk about that.
All events, he's never frustrated by circumstances.
He's not open to like just figuring out
what's happening later.
And he's responding to it as it happens.
That's not what we believe about God.
Uh, it does not limit the will of the creature,
nor does it make God the author of sin.
So I would say that there's a measure of question
that will come up with that,
but that's part of God's sovereignty,
is there's a mystery of how it works.
But we'll talk about it a little bit later.
Uh, salvation by grace.
So you can see that there's, um, God in his grace
and mercy chosen to redeem a people to himself.
So that is what we get to what we typically think.
Those other ones, most Christians would believe the
authority of scripture, most Christians would say
some form of sovereignty of God.
This is where the systems begin to
differ a little bit salvation by grace specifically,
and this is what you typically hear of five points
and whatever you want to call it there,
but I referenced a lot of them.
Sunday. Didn't say specifically the names of those
because it's, it's just part of what we teach in there.
But I do wanna articulate what, what some would say, uh,
would be reform theology, that unconditional election
that God from Eaternity past has chosen
to save a great multitude
of sinners, which no man can number.
That's going back to the covenant with Abraham.
But it's God from Eaternity past chosen
to save limited atonement,
particular redemption is another way to put that,
that Christ took the judgment for the sin
of the elect upon himself, paid
for their lives with his death.
Uh, he didn't make salvation just possible.
He actually obtained salvation for those that he had chosen.
So that's, uh, a question.
We'll get to that total depravity man.
We're, we're helpless, we're sinners.
And that has so comprehensively affected us
that we can't please God,
and we can't work our way out of it.
We're not gonna naturally seek to know God.
We're not gonna want to have anything to do with God
unless God would prompt us
and change something in us to then turn us towards him,
irresistible grace, that God is
in our natural state by ourselves.
We resist God,
but the grace of God working in our heart, we,
we then desire what he wants us to desire.
We previously resisted
that God does not fail in saving his people.
And then perseverance of the saints common,
you might have heard it said once saved, always saved.
I don't really like that phrase, but perseverance
of the saints, that God protects his
saints from falling away.
Salvation is eternal. And we saw why
'cause the ceiling of the Holy Spirit, that sort of thing
as we go, okay?
So that's, that's a quick summary of what
theology is typically known as.
What do others believe? And also, if,
if I don't line up fully with those five, which again,
this is a system, this is not the gospel,
this is a system of explaining something.
It's a bucket that we place things in to try
to hold it together, right?
But if I don't line up with all that,
am I not a Christian like that's legitimately been asked?
Don't hear us say that. What we're having here is an
intramural debate, right?
So we're differing on some of the, the nuances
and some of the things that we see it work out implications.
But the big rocks, remember
the big rocks are the salvific things.
Now this talks about salvation a lot, doesn't it?
So there's a bit of this sort of, what is it?
Big rock, small rock, sand.
It, it does do some of those things,
but I don't want you to hear us say that you,
if you're not agreeing with all five of those things,
that you're not a Christian.
Because there's leaders in our church all over the place.
There's church members all over the place
that don't line up with all five of those things.
So don't hear that. Okay? So what do others believe?
What, where does, where do other people stand
on those, those things?
Well, going back to this development of the doctrine,
there was a man named Pelagius who came
to persuade people of their own free will
to live a Christian life.
Like he looked at the commandments God had given
and said, how could it be just for God
to give a commandment that we couldn't keep?
The law is righteous.
God is righteous, the freedom to keep the commandment so,
so clearly, that's gotta be the way.
Well, Augustine shows up
and Augustine says, no,
actually the law is righteous
expresses what we're commanded to do.
We can't do it though because of sin. He's given.
It's good, but we can't do it.
Grace is the only reason we're able to obey the law.
And so God gave us the law to expose us
that we can't keep it.
And so we need him. We need his grace to follow it.
We need grace. Our inability is
not just physical, it's moral.
And so then they came to a council
that de declared thatas was not right in his view.
If by nature none of us can do what God calls us to do,
grace is necessary.
Who gives grace? God does.
And only he controls and dispenses that.
So that was part of the development of this, uh, this,
this belief system that came from Augustine into the creeds.
And then you see it show up again with the reformation.
But here's where it's kind of, there's,
it's called semi pianism.
It's a bit of an alternative.
It's similar to what it was,
and it tries to mediate some things.
But what it says is that God's grace comes to us
to strengthen a weak will, not
to give it the ability to do what is right.
So the question then is, is our will just weak
in our sin state?
Or are we dead and unable to do anything?
Well, the way we read that is the Bible says we're dead in
our trespasses and sins.
We have no ability. No one seeks God, no one is righteous.
And so we'd even push back on that a little bit,
that the Bible seems to indicate that we are unable
in ourselves in any way
unless God completely changes us from death to life
to actually seek to do what is right in God's eyes.
So I wanna go back through those five things
and kind of talk about where people would land
on other things there.
Um, so on their own, humans can do nothing good.
That's that one of that we're totally depraved, kind
of consistently dead in that
no one naturally desires to seek Christ.
Most people agree in some form of that.
Although there is that bit of just like, we're just weak.
We're not fully dead. Well, no, we're, we're dead.
So then that, there's the view that,
that God looked ahead from eternity past
and chose those who would choose him, that he for knew
and saw ahead, that people would choose him,
and that's who he chose.
That's a little bit different way of seeing it,
rather than unconditional election, that God
is not choosing based on anything in that person
or anything they would do.
The limited atonement one, the particular redemption one,
there's some different different views on that which say
that Jesus dies for everyone,
but his death only redeems believers, uh,
that he laid down his life for everyone
and then only gets applied to some.
So there's some different opinions
about the atonement there.
Uh, some would believe that you can choose
to reject God's attempt to save them.
So the irresistible grace that God's gonna save, those
who he's gonna save, he calls, he's gonna save them.
Others would say he calls and and they can resist that.
And they can choose not to be saved in that sense.
And then there's the, like I said, perseverance
of the saints that once saved, always saved idea
that if someone is a believer sealed by the Holy Spirit,
they'll persevere in faith until the end.
Some people believe that you can reject your
salvation and you can lose it.
So you can see there's these kind of, it turns into camps.
But what I hope you see is that there actually is a lot of
kind of meshing and crossing over that.
There is some things that we've got questions there.
We've got some, some things that we need
to discern out there.
That's, it's part of it.
But it's important because from whatever
doctrine you choose, a lot
of other doctrines flow from that.
And a lot of things are implications from that
and it shapes your worldview.
But again, there are well-informed,
true faithful Christians on all on
both sides of that debate.
For example, Methodists would lean more on that other side
of things, uh, very much more the um, kind
of helping grace.
They call it that God can call,
but you can choose to reject it.
You can lose your salvation.
Not all Methodists believe that either,
but that's part of some of those that you can get there.
Presbyterians tend to be more reformed in that.
But, but we'd look at that
and say, are your big rocks, right?
We true Christians. And we can walk together in some
of there, there's gonna be questions and some things.
That's why maybe there's some differences of denominations.
But we can get there to, uh, to see that man,
we're brothers and sisters in Christ.
Let's, let's walk together in some ways as well. Okay?
I wanna invite Aaron up here. Is tr here yet?
I don't think I saw him yet,
but I wanna invite Aaron to come up here
and we're gonna talk through a couple more questions
as we go here.
There's a lot more,
of course, as he's coming up here.
One I wanna talk first is can we lose our salvation?
So that, that was one of the questions
that there's a debate on.
Um, the common ar argument is that were those who fall away,
not just, they just weren't saved to begin with.
They tasted of it and then they fell away.
It's called the perseverance of the saints.
Preservation of the saints, you might say, once saved,
always saved assurance of salvation.
The evidence of someone being a Christian is
that they persevere until the end.
So we can't be truly sure really
until someone is actually on the other side.
We don't know. But here's what we see scripture wise,
that we get to that, that we can't lose it.
That's what our belief is.
We can't lose it or walk away from it.
Romans eight, those he four knew he predestined
to be conformed to the image of his son.
Um, those he predestined, he called those whom he called,
he justified, justified.
He also glorified Romans eight talks
as if it's already happened.
And then Romans, uh,
or John six, everyone
who my father gives me will come to me.
I'll never turn away anyone who comes to me.
'cause I've come down from heaven to do not my own will,
but the will of whom who sent me.
I should not lose any of those He's given to me.
So Jesus himself is saying that, uh, by the way,
I will never turn away anyone who comes to me.
That's a common question. Like, well, what if somebody wants
to believe if
what if they're not elect, but they wanna be saved?
We would say that they wanna be saved because they are,
because God has changed their heart.
Like I say, I I told you that story on Sunday of the man
who talked to me right before the service on that Sunday.
He said the day before, didn't want anything to do
with Jesus the next day.
I loved him, wanted to be saved.
Nobody convinced, like it wasn't an argument,
it wasn't a good reasonable state.
It was like God totally changed the heart to want.
So I will never turn away anyone who comes to me.
That means anybody who was coming to Jesus genuinely is
being drawn by God in that way.
Uh, so some people believe people can walk away from God,
that you can choose yourself to walk away.
Um, there's, there's scripture one Corinthians three.
If anyone's work is burned up, he'll suffer loss,
though he himself will be saved,
but only as through fire
like somebody might be walking away.
It seems prodigal son story.
And it sure seems like they're falling away.
20 years later, they finally wake up in the pigsty.
The father still loves his son, right?
The parables is his son. He still a son.
He never was not a son.
And he came back and the father received him in that.
But he would be saved through fire.
He might say some refining purification there.
So there's a question there.
Some people appear to be Christians for a while.
They turn out to be false, sometimes evil.
Jesus himself, Matthew seven says
away from me, I never knew you.
Uh, you all know people who you grew up with.
They were solid believers.
You thought in church they were growing and,
and leaders in high school ministry.
And, and then now they're completely abandoned their faith.
They don't. So it seemed like they were,
but then they turned, it turned out to be false,
sometimes evil, and they actually opposed the Lord.
We don't know. We, we can see
that Jesus did say there are people
who will sure seem like it.
And even Mark four, the parable of the sower,
he scatters the seed.
There's four different types of soil.
Only one actually ends up bearing fruit,
but two of them look like they were
bearing fruit for a while.
And so there is some of that that happens too, which again,
why the only reason, the only way we'll know
for sure is someone who perseveres all the way to the end.
And again, how do we know somebody might spend 90 years
of their life run away from Jesus?
And then right on their deathbed,
the Lord reach in their heart and saves 'em.
That happens too. So this is why some of this is like,
all right, we get so hard line on our system that we,
we start to lose the mystery of God working.
We don't wanna lose that. But those are things
that we would say, all right, so how do we handle,
you guys can start with this one.
How do we handle the scriptures that seem to oppose
what we just talked about when we say, Hey, okay, God
elects, um, God preserves.
And you, you look at those kind of reformed doctrines.
There are scriptures that seem to oppose this.
So it says Jesus died for all
or whoever whosoever would come.
How do we, how do we handle those texts?
Because they're there and,
and we don't wanna just like our,
some people in history have done is like literally remove
parts of the Bible that they didn't agree with.
We're not doing that. So
how do we handle those types of scripture?
Yeah, that's a great question. Excuse me.
The, uh, context of the passage is,
is the most important thing there.
Uh, and looking at the word all,
or whoever, whosoever, what's the meaning
behind those words?
Uh, if Jesus died for all, does that mean
that all are going to be saved?
Uh, we know that's not true. Not all people are saved.
So what does all mean?
We have to figure out what all means in the context
of the passage or whosoever believes
shall be saved.
What's the whosoever? Who's the whosoever? Is that everyone?
Is that a small group? Is that an elect group?
So I think immediate context is, uh, important with, um,
deciphering those verses.
You also have to look at the bigger picture of scripture
and the theological framework that we're talking about,
and how do these fit into that framework that we know
that the totality of scripture is building for us.
And we never want to take a just one verse
and make a, you know,
take a theological stand on just one verse.
But how does that fit into the larger picture of scripture?
So a couple of things there that I think of immediately.
Anything, yeah, there's, there's a couple scriptures
that would say, John three 16, the whoever, um,
you see whosoever, you see the term all a number of times.
It's almost always speaking of everyone in a group,
a class, or a category.
So think of when all of Jerusalem came out
to see John the Baptist,
every person in Jerusalem.
It was implying there of course,
that it was talking about all
different kinds of people came.
Not every human being came.
So you see all there even means a subset
of a whole group, right?
So that's where you have to discern.
That's why the hard part is you have to discern out
what is he saying there?
In, in all the cases that all
that the father gives me shall come to me.
The one who comes to me, I shall not cast out John six.
Um, he desire. Now this is a question.
First Timothy two, he desires all men to be saved
and come to the knowledge of the truth.
Same, same kind of idea. All, okay, what does that mean?
And I know some people might say,
were you playing semantic games there, man?
Like, no, we're just trying to interpret
what the scripture is saying
because again, I just said, all came out,
every person in Jerusalem came out to see John the Baptist.
No. So we know all doesn't mean every person there.
So we have to interpret, understand
what the scripture's talking about.
So really there's three ways you can understand.
There's one is universalism, that all people will be saved.
Well, we don't believe that that's a false belief.
The Bible's clear. Second means
then, then there's two other options.
There's the reference
to all means every person can accept Christ if they will
just choose to do so.
Okay, well that's one of the options We already saw that
that's one way people understand that.
But there's also the scriptures then that would indicate
that God is the one who ordains and God is the one who calls
and God is the one who changes hearts.
So we have to deal with that tension.
Then the third option is
that God is saying all meaning the elect, those
who he has chosen to save.
And so then there's questions still, but,
but you can see how there's, that's how it comes out.
This systems begin to diverge in those kind of things.
So these passages do not suggest Christ atonement is
for all persons without exception,
but for all people without distinction,
that's at least what we know, know.
'cause we look at revelation, every tribe, tongue
and nation represented.
So his atonement was not just for the Jews,
his atonement was for gentiles, all people,
all languages, all nations.
Someone will be there. We see in Revelation over and again,
Say that one more time, John. Say that without
Christ, atonement is for all persons with, it's not okay.
It's not for all persons without exception,
which would be universalism.
It's for all people without distinction.
Meaning you don't earn it.
There's classes, people get Jews, Gentiles like no,
it's, it's humans.
Christ saves, but not all persons without exception.
Okay, so let's, let's think of this.
Is it really that black and white?
So if we're thinking about systems reform, non-REM,
whatever, is it really this black and white?
Like can we be hard line about this stuff?
Can we be kind of, yeah, well this is what we need
to believe and everybody needs to believe this.
Can we be that way? Is it really?
Well, I think there is, there is one way
that we are saved, right?
Is that way perfectly explained in any human words?
I think we, we'd say no, right?
So that we're continuing to, to search scripture.
It's the idea of one of the, that we're always,
we're always reforming part
of reform theology is we're continuing to see what
scripture says and,
and let scripture interpret scripture that there is a,
there is clearly a yes and a no, a black and a white.
Now, can we perfectly put it into words in,
in five categories or five or, or four or six or 17?
Um, but there's a way in which God works
and there are scriptures that are very clear
and there are some that are less clear.
And so we were, that's kinda what we use the totality
of those to help us understand as best we can, uh,
God's work in salvation.
So I've gotten this question in this week,
but I've also heard this question a number
of times from other people.
So somebody's reading the Bible,
they don't really understand it, they can't get there.
Having trouble with some
of the Old Testament stuff seems harsh.
They, they've, they've grown up in the church,
believe like, okay, resurrection.
Like, it's hard to wrap my mind around that.
No evidence for it in there. Okay?
But like I want to believe,
but so much doesn't make sense.
And I'm wondering if the reason is because I'm not chosen.
Like I've had somebody ask me that question to my face and,
and they've wrestled with that reality of I wanna believe,
but I just don't, I I just can't get, I can't get there.
It seems like I can't get there.
How would you respond to somebody like that?
Am I, am I elect right?
Somebody's wrestling with that question
'cause they don't really feel saved.
How would you answer that?
Yeah, that's a tough one.
Uh, I think just by the nature of
wrestling with those things,
I could tell God is working on your heart
and working in your mind and, and maybe it's this process,
but he's, he's changing your heart, uh, to believe.
And um, sometimes it happens just like that for people
and sometimes it happens, you know, over time.
But, um, I would say that that's evidence
that God's working in your life.
Um, it doesn't mean necessarily that,
that you will believe eventually.
We don't know that for sure.
But, uh, I would say that's evidence that God is at work.
Yeah. And similarly, even the, even the conviction
of sin is a work of the Holy Spirit in your life.
And so encouraging people to, to lean into that even,
and then, and to the desire, we would say that the desire
to seek after God comes from the work
of the Holy Spirit in your life.
So it may be that he hasn't finished that good work
that he started, but he started a good work.
Um, and we, nobody can know who's elected
and who's not, except for those
who have ultimately professed their faith in Christ.
Um, we would say, yes, that person is iSelect
'cause we've seen the fulfillment of that work,
but up until that point, there's no way to know.
Yeah. And there's the, one
of my favorite stories is when the, the man comes
to Jesus says, Hey, my,
my daughter's sick, can you heal her?
And he's like, yeah, I can heal her if you believe.
He's like, whew, I believe to help my unbelief.
So he's of this wrestling moment of, yeah, I,
I know you can, but there's times I really doubt that too.
I don't really know if I'm all in on believing that.
And so that gives me a little solace at times for
that same spirit throughout the Psalms, you see things
where they're wrestling with the realities of
what they're experiencing in life
and they say, God, where are you?
In the very same psalm, they're like,
God, thank you for never leaving me.
Wait, didn't you just say, God? Where are you?
Because they didn't feel it at the time,
but then they know it's like limitations.
God, remind me again of your mercy.
I go back, I remember how good you are.
But that's the wrestling that we will go through.
It's, it's hard. And I would just say, yes,
good sign that you're there.
And, and let's just keep pressing into that.
So one of the questions that always comes up in this
is, why is this?
Or how is this fair?
When you think about predestination, what even in
that term define means,
which I'll, I'll do that in a second.
But what we commonly push back on in this is it feels like
it's unjust, you know, God,
how, how could you do this?
How could you save some and not others? Is it fair?
Well, here's the word predestined in the scripture is pro
orzo, which means determining beforehand,
ordaining, deciding ahead of time.
So predestination is God determining certain things
to occur ahead of time.
So Romans eight said, he cer determined certain individuals
be conformed to the likeness of his son,
be called justified, glorified believers being chosen.
We saw that in Ephesians one,
God in his sovereignty chooses certain
individuals to be saved.
Now this is not willy-nilly outside of his character.
God is just, God is good, God is merciful.
We looked at all his attributes, big rock, right?
So he's not just kind of throwing darts at the wall.
There's a personal relational aspect to this,
but the same objection still comes up.
Is it unfair?
So why would God choose certain individuals and not others?
Is that fair?
Yeah, that's kind of a two-edged sword.
If you want God to be fair, um, none of us would be saved.
Uh, we would all end up in hell.
Um, so we gotta be really careful there by saying
we want God to be fair, so he should save me
or he should save someone else.
If we wanted God to be fair,
I don't think we would like the outcome.
So God is not fair.
Um, fairness is, uh, something that comes later after sin.
We, we compare ourselves to others. We say that's not fair.
God is just, um, he is unchangeable,
immutable and his character's always the same,
but he does not deal, uh, with all men the same.
They, we all have different paths.
We all have different, uh, different stories in our life,
different roadblocks, different challenges.
And uh, to say
that is not fair is to
put ourselves in God's place and try to play God.
Uh, we have to be really careful
with the word fair, I think.
And as sinners, uh, to
blame God or to to discredit God
for something we don't think is right, is really,
really a dangerous place to be.
Uh, what's not fair is that Christ, that God sent his son
to die on our behalf.
Uh, but to say that God is not fair
and uh, to to, to to,
to push on him something that is part of the sin nature,
I think is unfair in our own, uh, in our own way.
Um, I don't know if I'm making any sense there,
but that's a, to say God is not fair, uh,
is I think is is unfair of us to do that.
He's holy, he's righteous, he never makes mistakes.
He is perfect and without sin.
And for us to say who are sinful, fall
and broken, that's not fair is a little bit out
of, uh, outta whack.
Yeah. So I think we have a, we have an an awareness
or understanding of fairness that demands equal outcomes.
Fairness is equal treatment, right? Equal perspective.
And it can, it can mean either way.
But the fairness we're talking about is
not always equal outcomes.
Fairness is that he is treating everyone equally now
that there's an illustration given where, uh,
thinking about no one deserves anything from God,
therefore no one can object if he does
not receive anything from God.
So an illustration is a man walking into a group
of 20 people and randomly handing out money to five of them.
Now, the 15 people standing around
who didn't get any money would probably be upset, right?
Do they have a right to be upset?
No, because none of the 20 deserved money to begin
with, right?
They didn't have any expectation that this was coming.
There was no owing anyone money.
And he walks in and hands a few of that.
He simply decided to be gracious to some of those.
And I, I don't want that to sound cold,
but that's what he was getting to.
The idea of like, well, I I use the illustration
of the orphanage on Sunday.
I mean, what about the others who didn't get
adopted out of the orphanage?
What they feel like this is unfair.
They would've loved to be adopted as well, right?
And so that sounds so cold,
but this is where we have to realize God is God.
We are not. And we lean on his mercy.
We lean on his grace,
and he, he has mercy on whom he will.
And the fact that all of us deserve wrath
and hell is part of the reality of
what we believe in scripture.
Every one of us deserves that.
That's why the point was humility and worship on Sunday.
If we believe in Jesus as our savior, then
we should be dumbfounded, stunned by that.
And if we start thinking implications of what about this
and what about that we're missing,
I think really the the main point what he's done.
And we can't miss that as we go forward.
And Romans nine has a lot about that,
about injustice on God's part.
And Paul is defending the argument.
He's saying, well, how can we say these things about that?
Uh, there's a parable of Matthew 20 that kind
of talks about the giving of money
and uh, the people working in the vineyard
and some worked all day, some worked half the day,
some worked, and the owner gave them all the same amount at
the end and they were like, wait a second, I worked all day.
And he's like, yeah, but you agreed to that and,
and I agreed to that with these and, and it's my money.
I can give what I want.
And so that was what he gave to some,
they deserve this others more than they deserve.
It's not unfair to give extra
to some even they're less deserving others. So
Yeah, I think that's, that's one reason it's important
that we look at
and study the attributes of God as we approach these types
of topics because we have to rest on those things.
We know that scripture teaches us about God,
about his sovereignty, about his omniscience, um, and, and
and his goodness and his holiness and his justness.
And we can lean into that, um, into those attributes that,
that we know to be true, to be true without question.
And those should help us shape our view
of these doctrines when there are scriptures that seem
to be in question
or people raise questions over certain scriptures
that we lean totally on who we know God to be,
um, and how he relates to his people.
Okay, so we got about nine, 10 minutes left.
One of the common questions as well as you can see,
there's a lot of common questions to this, isn't there?
Um, what about free will?
Are we just robots?
If this is what we believe about salvation
and God does it's God's work
and does this just make us robots?
Well, there's a concept, and I'm not even sure if I'm saying
it right, antinomy, antinomy, I dunno how you say it.
Anti A-N-T-I-N-O-M-Y antinomy
or anami, I'm not sure exactly which way to say it,
but it, the word means an apparent conflict
or contradiction between two things.
And so between clearly established biblical truth.
And so the root of that is human logic,
because the problem's not in the divine revelation.
The problem is in our limited understanding
and ability to discern how those things work together.
Those are not contradictions.
This is an antinomy or anno me.
So the Bible, let me give you an example.
The Trinity, the Bible teaches the God,
the Father's God, God the Son is God.
God the Spirit is God.
When you put them all together,
they're not three gods, they're one God.
Each is fully God. Yet there's,
but one God, human logic, whole boy, right?
But we could get to tri theism if we try to understand it,
but we're ignoring all the pastors say God is one.
So we have to say God is one.
We agree that God the Father,
son the Holy Spirit are distinct yet one.
So we don't try to promote one over the other.
We we come to say
what the Bible says about this, right?
Same kind of thing here with salvation.
Does it occur by believing? Yes.
Is man responsible for believing? Yes.
Does God desire men to be saved? Yes.
Does God elect some to salvation? Yes.
Can we fully work this all out
within the limits of human logic?
No. However, we must not promote one
of those truths over another.
We will achieve biblical imbalance.
This is a dangerous place.
It creates wrong beliefs and disunity.
So as we're talk, listen, as we're talking about all this,
this is just try to give the background
what you hear all the time is what a call
to repent and belief.
And I'm not saying, hey,
if you're elect, repent and belief, right?
That's foolishness.
What we're saying is there is a command in scripture
to believe, and yet God elects to salvation
and God works salvation.
So, so that's where we're starting
to logically figure out how to untangle that.
No, we can't, we gotta keep it, we gotta keep it here.
And so does this somehow, does this irresistible grace, this
God doing his thing, does that conflict
with man's free will somehow?
Like how do we get to that? How?
Because we are supposed to believe we're commanded
to believe, but God does it.
How does this, does, does that not walk in conflict somehow?
How does that work out?
Go ahead. I think, I mean, the answer is no,
it's not in conflict because it's because it's true.
And so it's how we think about it
that creates that antenna.
I'm just gonna go with one. Go ahead and commit to it.
Um, but that, I think it, it gets back to the fact that
the reality is yes, we, we choose
to put our faith in Christ,
but we don't have the ability to do that without the work
of the Holy Spirit, without the, without the work
of God in our lives.
Without him giving that free gift of grace for us
to have faith, to repent and believe it's only through him
and so on the, on the front end it does, it feels like,
yes, I'm making that choice.
But the more we grow
and understand who God is, we understand He did
that in me, right.
That yeah, I did it.
But he, I mean like I walked down the aisle,
I raised my hand and prayed the prayer, said the words,
but it was his spirit already at work in me doing
that regenerative work, putting that seed of faith in me.
Yeah. And we do have free will to some degree.
If somebody says that to you, ask them
what do they mean by free will?
And um, you know, we have freedom of choice.
You chose to come here tonight.
Uh, but your will,
I would argue your will is not free.
You're, you're bound.
We, we read in Ephesians chapter two that your bound
in darkness and death and, and sin and trespasses.
And so your will is not free.
It's free to sin, it's free to, to,
to make decisions in this fallen world.
But your will is not free, it's bound, it's not free
to choose to love God, to believe in Christ, to to,
to believe him by faith.
So your will is bound.
Even though we believe it's free, it is bound
and it takes what Tiar was was saying,
it takes the regenerative power of the Holy Spirit to,
to bring us back to life.
And then we find that our will, uh, is free.
Yeah. 'cause the Bible never says that man's will is free
of outside influences.
A person is only as free as his nature is free.
And so his will is limited to
that which is within his nature.
So like in our nature state, sin state, we're free
one direction, not even free in a sense
to understand the things of God.
So the fact that God moves within our will, creates a desire
for him is not a violation of free will.
It's a reprieve from a depraved will.
Like our will is depraved
and God grants us a reprieve from that.
So we can then desire.
Well I wanna give spurge in the last word here.
Uh, he's a lot smarter than we are.
So, uh, this is what he said about this.
So trying to reconcile God's sovereignty,
human responsibility.
I heard David Platt say those are unexplainable friends,
but undeniable truths, God's sovereignty,
he's in full control, human responsibility
that we are responsible somehow.
Okay? So think that this is what Spurgeon said, uh,
150 plus years ago.
He said The system of truth revealed in the scriptures is
not simply one straight line, but two.
And no man will ever get a right view of the gospel
until he knows how to look at the two lines at once.
For instance, I read one book of the Bible, the spirit
and the brides say, come let him
that hears say come let him.
That's thirsty. Come
who whosoever will let him take the water of life freely.
Yet I'm taught in another part of the same inspired word
that it is not of him that wills nor him that works,
but him, that shows mercy, God.
So I see in one place God in providence, presiding overall,
and yet I see and cannot help seeing that man acts
as he pleases, that God has left his actions in a great
measure to his own free will.
Now, if I were to declare that man was so free to act
that there was no control of God over his actions,
I should be driven very near to atheism.
And if on the other hand, I should declare that God
so overrules all things that man's not free enough
to be responsible, I should be driven at once
to antinomianism, which means no law
or fatalism that God.
So here's how he concludes that God predestines,
and yet that man is responsible are two facts
that few can see clearly.
They are believed to be inconsistent
or contradictory to each other.
If then I find taught in one part of the Bible
that everything is for ordained, that is true.
And if I find in another scripture that man is responsible
for all his actions, that is true, and it is only my folly
or foolishness that leads me to imagine
that these two truths can ever contradict each other.
I do not believe they can be welded into one upon any
earthly anvil, but they certainly shall be in eternity.
So here's the image. Watch this.
They are two lines that are so neatly parallel
that the human mind, which pursues them farthest,
will never discover that they converge, but they do converge
and they will meet somewhere in eternity, close
to the throne of God where all truth springs from.
And so we have to walk in a measure of humility
to embrace the truths of his word.
Even when we can't fully understand
or comprehend how these truths might work
or fit together, we have to walk in grace
and humility towards one another for our own beliefs,
our sys, like we have to walk in grace, humility
for ourselves in a way too.
All of us have have grown
and adapted and moved and tweaked and taken a journey,
and we're still not done.
Every time we go to the Bible,
we should be growing in our understanding of who he is
and what he's done, how salvation works, all that,
which should again, lead us to humility.
We should never walk around
self-righteous about our belief system.
I'll talk about that this Sunday actually about some things
that we kind of stand in judgment over other people
because they don't have it figured out like we do.
That's a dangerous place to be.
So hold your beliefs, yes, let's hold our beliefs firmly
but also graciously
and open handedly a little bit that
we're gonna grow every one
of us in our beliefs and understandings of these things.
So we're gonna be here, I got some resources up here,
uh, including this is actually on our website.
It's called The Origin of Salvation.
Dennis Newkirk, previous senior pastor, wrote this, uh,
a number of years ago, but it's the origin of salvation
and Salvation of work of God or man.
Uh, so this is kind of a position paper we have
as an elder council
and then a bunch of other resources up here you can look
at and come look at.
But then we're going to, uh, to be available,
probably they gotta use this room here in a little bit.
So probably out there more as we can to, uh, talk about
questions you may have follow ups you may have.
Uh, but then let's just pray as we go forward in this.
Lord, we, we look at this and we could talk for hours
and hours and hours more about these things and questions
and implications.
And so, God, we just, I pray for me, for us, for this,
this body, these who've heard this tonight, uh,
that either maybe for the first time they're wrestling
with this, it's all new,
or maybe this was a, an affirmation for them
and just continuing to open their hearts to the humility,
uh, that they have before you.
Or maybe there's some, some pushback and questions.
I pray God, you'd give us grace that we,
we believe the same big rocks here
and there's some difference here.
We can nuance this here and there.
But really, God, we see the end game of this, as I said,
Sunday, the end game is, is really the,
the same God you've called us to repent and believe.
And we are called to go take the gospel to all people.
We don't have a radar telling us who is who.
We just are called to preach this gospel of good news,
of salvation in Christ alone.
We grow because of you. We know that's true.
God, we know that it's because of your work in our hearts.
So Lord, give us a measure of
dependence, of understanding.
Yeah, but also that humility to say, God,
there's gonna be some mystery here.
That door that we walk through to salvation.
You, you've called us all yes to come,
but we look on the other side that you,
you called us from the, before the foundation of the world
and gave us the faith to open that door.
So thank you God for that.
And I pray for anyone in this room or,
or those that they love are struggling with the faith
that they want to have or, or think they have.
And there's, there's some unsettledness
in their heart right now.
I pray God, that this would not,
that the enemy would not snatch this away,
but it would be deep rooted, good soil,
and it would bear fruit in their heart
that they would instead of wondering and questioning
and more doubts and more turmoil in their heart,
they would instead look
and see your goodness, your work, your salvation.
And they would just say, Jesus, you are mine.
I'm yours, you in my place. That's my hope.
I pray for more to believe that Lord, this,
this gives us encouragement, that you have guaranteed
that you will save from every tribe, tongue, and nation.
So when our missionaries go to the hard places, they know
that there will be someone, at least one who will believe.
So we don't give our lives for nothing.
God, we don't have to hold the pressure of being the one
that's so persuasive that we get people to be saved
because we're great at preaching the gospel.
No, it's because your work is happening. We trust you.
Do that more. God, we pray for your grace
and mercy as we go tonight to wrestle with your word.
I thank you that these will drive us to your word, to study,
to consider, to think and pray.
Ask your Holy Spirit to illuminate as one Corinthians says.
So lead us in that, lead us in a, a gracious way together,
uh, as we focus on the main things, the number one
and most important things.
And these things can be intramural, debates
and good questions and conversations,
but God, we wanna focus on the main things
and worship you in spirit and in truth.
In Jesus' name we pray. Amen. Amen. Amen.
All right, thanks everybody. Love y'all.